non port de la ceinture usage du
téléphone et absence de clignotants
autant de mauvaises habitudes qui
peuvent coûter la vie mardi 7 juin une
opération de contrôle routier a été mise
en place sur tout le département
un moyen de diminuer le nombre
d'accidents sur les routes sur le même
créneau horaire
dans les neuf circonscriptions
d'agglomération des départements on mène
simultanément des contrôles routiers
d'ampleur vous voyez on a des bleus
débloquer un certain nombre d'effectifs
n'a en tout j'ai à peu près une
vingtaine de policiers qui sont
mobilisés sur ce point de contrôle
pendant deux heures sur les 20 points de
contrôle 468 véhicules ont été examinées
au total 86 infractions relevées une
action qui permet aussi à la police de
sensibiliser les conducteurs pour être
visible pour avoir une action de
communication parce que c'est pas
uniquement répressif c'est aussi très
préventif ce qu'on essaye de faire et le
but éventuellement bas de pouvoir
toucher et
voir certains comportements routiers qui
sont mauvais pour pouvoir les corriger
par la suite ces contrôles de grande
ampleur ont lieu une à deux fois par
mois
à l'issue de cette soirée trois mesures
de gardes à vue ont été prononcées dont
une pour port d'armes illégal en mai
sept personnes sont décédées sur les
routes dans les yvelines